I didn't know this side of you but now
you're going to be in Chicago on
Broadway I had no idea that you had like
Broadway dreams oh my gosh since I was a
kid and I went to school for theater and
I lived in New York for a while trying
to pursue it and I just it wasn't
getting anywhere so I mov to LA to try
to you know make a name for myself with
hopes of coming back one day and doing
it and full circle 20 years later it's
like here we are full circle yeah that's
amazing are you so excited so excited
I'm also terrified but that's what
rehearsal if you can survive Dancing
with the Stars I think you're going be
it's just a grueling I've had a couple
people on here that have done that and
it's just such a they say behind the
scenes they're like man it is it's
hardcore oh yeah I'm I'm very excited
and at least like with the show you're
learning the routine for the show you're
not learning different routines every
day I think that'll be really nice
because that is one thing with Like
Dancing with the Stars is like every 5
days you're doing something completely
different which is cool to break the
monotony I like the creativity in that
but just it's you know it's a little
you're GNA be so great at the routine
with Chicago by the time they end it
because you're you know doing it
repeatedly so so yeah let's hope so yeah
you're gonna kill it you're gonna kill
it so what are your thoughts on the new
season of vandercom what's what's
happening you know I haven't seen it um
did they not show it to y'all like
before no we usually get the episodes
like a few days before they air so I'm
sure we'll see them you know a few days
before that day in January when it
starts airing I think our show thrives
when it's at its realist and so this
season was very real to film so I think
it'll be good yeah I imagine a
[Music]
[Applause]
difficult thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home